des télévisions par dizaines et une
cinquantaine de radios du monde entier
leur vision pile h en rendez vous de 13h
et à 13h04 pour être précis mille cinq
cent cinquante cinq jours après son
extradition de bolivie klaus barbie
s'est retrouvé dans le box des accusés
du palais de justice de lyon pour la
première fois en france les débats d'un
procès d'assises seront entièrement
filmé et enregistré par quatre caméras
installées en permanence dans la salle
d'audience tous les soirs un magistrat
récupérera les cassettes qui seront
mises joue scellés et expédiés sous
bonne escorte dans une chambre forte des
archives départementales du rhône
les enregistrements ne pourront être
visionnées librement par le grand public
que dans cinquante ans mais ce n'est
qu'à partir de l'an 2007 que les
cassettes du procès pourront être
consultés par des historiens à titre
individuel qu'après l'accord conjoint du
garde des sceaux et du ministre de la
culture